many of my discussions are centered
around someone who has a real issue or
bone to pick with someone else and I'll
listen and I'll listen and I'll listen
because a lot of times people just want
to feel understood
but then when they're finished feeling
understood they feel like they've had a
shoulder to cry on I will always ask the
question I wonder why
Jim would have said that or I wonder why
Gail
feels that way and the person will
usually say something like well I have
no idea I'm not Jim and I'll say well no
I understand that but if I think about
Jim
I wonder what motivates him and and if I
can start a discussion like that more
often than not people will say well you
know he was pretty depressed over that
issue last year or she got passed over
for that promotion so maybe she's still
feeling defensive about that and it's my
way of not manipulation at all but
helping someone gently but directly
start to see things from another's
perspective and that leads into helping
them try to understand what someone's
intent is and when we can get that type
of a conversation going it's it's not
always easy but it becomes easier to
start to assume maybe that everyone
doesn't have it out for you or bad
intent but in general people have good
intent when people have emotions that
are high whether they're high because
they're frustrated or where they're high
cuz they're happy first and foremost
they just want to be understood we
listen through what the late dr. stephen
r.covey used to say and we listen
through this autobiographical lens and
then we have this autobiographical
response so we listen with the intent to
reply not to understand but the most
effective people and therefore the most
successful influential people they
listen with the intent to understand so
reflective listening and this is nothing
new but boy it's new to practice it
because everybody reads about it hears
about it and yet I see them not model it
and I'll tell you modeling it is magic
when someone says to me gosh I can't
believe that they put that policy out
I'm so frustrated with this thing and
blah blah blah
I will listen listen listen and all I
will say and it's not it's not a I'm not
manipulative it's just because I want to
understand I'll say it sounds like
you're pretty fresh
traded with the policy well yeah I am
because they'll go on for five minutes
or twenty more minutes and they'll
finish that and I'll just comment on so
it seems like it's really got you
considering maybe a change in your
career I'm making this up but you do
reflective listening take the time to do
it you will start to get to the heart of
the real issue and 90% of the time it's
not in this case the policy it's
something way underneath and all I had
to do is listen and reflect back to the
person what I'm hearing them say and
what I I'm thinking they're feeling
there is a time then for clarifying
questions not probing not prying not
trying to judge or agree or disagree but
saying so am I am i clear and
understanding that you think the policy
is wrong because of such-and-such
that's a clarifying question or am i
understanding you correctly that you
believe Joe has taken more vacation than
anybody else in the department that's a
clarifying question it's not you're not
agreeing or disagreeing you're not
prying into or trying to figure somebody
out you're just trying to clarify and
understand it's like giving someone
psychological air or oxygen if you will
and when we take the time to do that we
actually start to resolve things much
quicker than if we jump in ahead of time
and try and resolve it without knowing
what's at the heart of the issue
[Music]